humph comb resumes welcome to Skip's
Patti you know the drill by now we're
gonna start chapter four second lines
chapter baby who knows honestly maybe
the head like I surprised Shepherd six
I've been pretty cool new game I wonder
which cat which characters are left
honestly I'm I'm curious
yes we would like to see the intro what
the [ __ ] okay this oh my god I got a
sense of that but they're so cute
sprites what you hiding under your hands
they're a little bad there are no
secrets in this bath what then what okay
okay then it's worse hard I ever see
what's with okay five
cops on me tighter like a mob mom mamas
don't do that got a point that out there
in case someone is confused I don't like
her voice now when I'm looking with your
mother comrade secretary nope Anna
okay yeah okay then what you and me
mother my family doesn't know now you're
bossy
it's got on a paper on it yeah buddy for
don't wanna
[Music]
Oh outside the school oh yeah have fun
hurrah
okay this is maybe not something to talk
to your daughter about denied
not exactly you're not to be like that
if we're gonna be a doll what I that
don't deal II doesn't make no sense
oh so now we play as her forgot about
her
I guess she's the last piece of the
puzzle I can imagine the last chapter a
lot of stuff happening sorry she doesn't
remember where she is I like her voice
she knows or her she's the only one
alone
[Music]
the one that obviously didn't work
Oh No
well that means she's gonna die right oh
oh what is that oh it's a stomach oh no
oh nice hide [ __ ] those baby
[ __ ] how can they appear in all
dimensions by night and I think other
ones
how about we don't follow them maybe not
what is she doing now this is still
intro chapter four like we played for so
many hours but it doesn't feel like that
much you know considering there's only
two chapters left it seems hard to
imagine that that's it now we're inside
Russia now we keep jumping
what yeah then it makes more sense that
we played us
so we gotta find Yuka they went in here
right oh oh oh well I don't know how it
should be honest I hope we Oh God
where's that coming from
or you cat paints my heart to hear it
you come this way
all right well I guess we go that's why
then oh it changed we can only go this
way um oh all right all right then
that's a that's a lovely ah hello that
chap higher down that chip tap it seems
the body of a high schooler however it
seems to have just died here mere hours
only just died in mere hours okay
minutes already even moments ago there's
a yellow sheet of notebook paper on the
floor next to the body the shakiness of
the lettering and the contents of the
memorandum suggests that its writer was
on the verge of death while before pen
touch paper I need water so badly I'm
hungry
sure but I can deal with the hunger it's
the thirst I can't send the other guy I
was with a Satoshi Matsubara he tried
drinking that filthy tap water from the
sink in the bathroom but he threw it all
up almost immediately and it burned in
his chest and its throat was so badly
that he wound up dying Wow
I tried to think outside the box they've
been going so far as to drink my own
spit but needless to say it didn't help
matters one bit that's right my tongue
so swallow at this point that I can't
even talk we didn't really get anything
out of that but a lot of times you have
to read all the notes to progress or
whatever for example to find the hallway
you'd have to read the note took me
forever to find it but I guess it
doesn't really matter I guess it doesn't
look like we can go much here I guess
we'll have to go too
we're gonna have to do that trick again
well I guess we'll
well oh I wonder what's gonna happen -
wheeler oh hello that's wonderful that's
it oh yeah we have the tape now so
that's problem yeah yeah that's the only
fingers crossed right now Jesus all
right somehow we need to find someone
else maybe we need to we can push
something I don't know oh hello thanks
appreciate it
oh what's that say call never sick huh
huh oh my god we got to save Naomi now
we know what was that is that the
crystal the caramel okay damnit not
interested in that and god damn it
their mom or whatever Jesus I'm not
interested in the penis enlargment come
on
stop calling me oh jesus [ __ ] yeah we
got our phone I mean what else would we
do
let's check the bathrooms you never know
these days what is this a that's what I
say when I poop is this crazy psycho I
don't want to meet wait a sec I prefer
the same take her place Oh No
is she insane too now sorry I clicked
away run back
[Music]
I agree
oh wait oh now he talks awkward you
don't walk in on girls pooping everyone
else's there's no indication that
anyone's inside goddammit goddammit it's
probably gonna yell at me when I said
there we go oh let's take uh Cinco Cinco
come on cow part noise Naomi oh god what
do I do now God whatever they're trying
to hold her up against the wall really
do
mango yeah yeah sand on Bucky Dent I
don't trust a bucket while still ups
supporting nominees shoulder with a her
upper body dropping between the back
wall of the bathroom and his head
drooping such as she reached behind him
and fiddled with the knots at the base
of the moon news somehow or another he
managed to listen to ropes crap
against all odds it seemed that now me
would live really oh yeah ha ha ha
it's a wonderful toilet
so she's not insane either he's got a
boner
yeah must hurt like crazy cruzita - kini
Seiko got my degree da-da-da-da-da
chemita
no sorry about such puny
no one knows no no she doesn't know
about sake oh god damn it
goddamnit she was the one that saved her
[Music]
what was sterile
there you go Krista mama Donna the cigar
bar you got the money
is he hot tub yeah well you did she knew
[Music]
come on I am I don't got the beginner
die Java mighdal season I suck young way
more yeah
[Music]
go go go
there you go thank you
[Music]
continuity ami de Chivo Rocio Nnamani
Syrian I don't know how do you know
probably not anyway let's do you know I
don't see good I know
oh yeah we talked to her touched by the
Kurds will that mean that's what I
happen to teach another conductor
she's older now me I see her I decide to
study Italian how about you find UK come
on Yoga Yoga Yoga hi a Camino two bodies
there I do not know click on your move
but those sickos goodnight yeah how is
it possible those dakuten it must have
been the phone go to the one occupies
your thought she knew hello Misaki just
marine yacht was that even mean
don't you come to request that you can
go hey dotted hide in your own room
because she took it okay what's going on
okay Nick I get you got a new coach go
and look at all
want oka she wished not to ride on
hoglets not da cunha to Carini's 30 days
ha ha ha
you kinda what I don't quit no me
good luck sure come on sir 888 I get off
yesterday
oh mama mia pizzeria Oh God she keeps
tripping man
oh-ho she's probably proposing no hang
in there now may come on that's not a
good placement that's a terrible place
to deliver we're gonna go on without her
we're gonna have a choice
Tony Kaku supermo dr. Curie oh all right
baby
let's do a quick save so we have to find
another person somehow I don't know how
I don't know why
yesterday's all about the blue blue sky
and all that I can see yeah it's just my
nail M&P
[Music]
that's hot hey I gotta wattle Oconee kit
has done the walkway was just at the
bottom of the stairs to the right all
right thanks for reminding me
let's no way guess we're in the
different space man
[Music]
what's that I don't like that sound
Kazami got it so tiny they buy how does
that mean that smelly thing what'd he
say he's gonna kill it
for my knee mommy Citterio he notes in
washing co-co-co Sisera no no what the
[ __ ] make an hour then you must deny you
come on over to Attica tell an anonymous
deny Ibaka
madam is seen on Dakara and he must in
either ha ha
so you got a bad character home Tony
screw you night cousin again you're
telling Ibaka Jesus
and they were still under because their
release that's that's very nice moody
going on not only wow you're a positive
person aren't you
who the [ __ ] is this
oh that's some nice background on him
like expose no yokai what did she find
him there
well II she peed right do something you
gotta you gotta
oh no she still hasn't peed what does
that mean
[Music]
yeah they did it themselves main well
that's one way to use bathroom I suppose
every time you try to open it slams into
the corpse and bounces close there's a
student ID name tag on the floor alright
so we can contact their ID name tags
nope alright well let's go back to you
Ken what are you doing he turns him on
[Laughter]
okay gonna be like that he lasts like a
girl
take that back he lasts like I yeah you
and a thunder what is happening don't
you dare touch him you okay you got your
bacon oh yeah
he cook really okay oh he always wanted
to know all right [ __ ] I hate to do
this but everything has to come to an
end
even your butt cheeks go ahead and leave
a like if you enjoyed watching bliss
that's the sky camera today and I will
head butt you today